quelques jours je vous ai parlé du
plâtre en pro le smartphone le plus haut
de gamme de huawei aujourd'hui je vous
parlais du pétrole ait qui n'est pas le
smartphone le mois ou deux gammes de
huawei mais qui fait partie de la gamme
p 30 vous avez le pétrole light qui est
sorti il n'y a pas très longtemps
le p 30 et ensuite le pétrole reprend ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est qu'on a
deux smartphones qui ont quasiment le
même nom et qui pourtant n'ont pas grand
chose en commun mise à part le fait
d'avoir un triple capteur à l'arrière
une caméra de celle ci à l'avant goutte
d'eau dans mon vin d'écran et les
boutons bon voila sinon l'adn de ces
fruits sont quand même relativement
différent le pétrole propre on est déjà
parlé donc aujourd'hui on va pas en
parler on va parler de pétrole light le
pitre en plaques est un smartphone qui
est assez intéressant et qui surtout
n'est pas très cher 369 euros
je vais vous expliquer en quoi ce p 30
light est intéressant pourquoi il faut
l'acheter actifs destinés surtout ce
qu'il faut l'acheter
[Musique]
ce que j'aime bien mais qu'on va jouer
ça s'accélère stade étant ce qu'ils sont
en train de construire un écosystème
complet ils ont une marque qui monte
énormément des produits qui sont
franchement sexy
ce produit est intéressant et surtout il
est compatible avec celui là le macbook
13 j'ai déjà parlé ya pas très longtemps
je vous montrais il arrive à communiquer
ensemble extrêmement facilement grâce à
ovi share c'est un truc qui coule et se
paie 30 selon safa suis là je me perds
et 7 p 30 light est plutôt cool première
chose on a regardé ce cas dans la boîte
vous allez voir c'est faire un tour très
très très rapide bon c'est pas sur la
boîte toi nous a fait un truc de fou
furieux très blanc très simple on va
regarder hyper rapidement ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur
bon si vous avez le smartphone vous vous
en douterez petit bloc de recharge
rapide de la recharge en usb type si par
croyez moi sur parole
et là vous avez des petits écouteurs
voilà c'est tout pour la botte vous
voyez je vous avais dit que salle est
rapide maintenant on se concentre sur le
smartphone on a un des gradés qui est
plutôt verbe le violine vraiment très
très très sympa ses côtés twilight
j'adore vraiment ce boulot qui a été
fait parce que ça nous permet d'avoir
des dons qu'ils sont vraiment très très
beau avec tous des reflets ya vrai jeu
de lumière à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
hyper sympa au triple module photo qu'on
retrouve ces dans la gamme p 30 capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est situé il
fut que plutôt pas trop mal intégrés bon
c'est un grand classique ça marche ici
nous ne parvient triple caméra xi a pas
de partenariat avec les cas pour ce
modèle à l'avant d'un écran avec une
petite goutte d'eau débord qu'on devine
sur le côté un montant qui est un peu
plus grand convoi la bomba il assez bien
intégré dans le thème là dessus huawei
enfin bon boulot sur le côté vous avez
bouton volume bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre haut parleur mono recharge en
usb type c vous avez ici votre prise
jack
là c'est le micro sur le flanc gauche
absolument rien sur le dessus vous avez
le tiroir de cartes sim soit vous pouvez
mettre deux cartes sim soit une carte
qu'ils passent une carte microsd jusqu'à
512 ig encore parlé et c'est tout vous
avez fait le tour de ce smartphone
on a quelque chose qui est extrêmement
efficace qui marche bien smartphones
bien jolie prise en main plutôt sympa on
peut l'utiliser à une main ne va pas
être très loin le mieux pour utiliser
c'est quand même d'avoir ces deux mains
dessus parce qu'on n'a pas d'écran qui
est trop petit on a un écran de 6,15
pouces résolution de 1312 pas remis
90 elle séduit fhd plus c'est une dalle
lcd alors ici pas de l'aide ici lcd
c'est une dalle ltps qui fonctionne
franchement bien on va pas avoir la même
qualité que si vous arrivez tout de
suite sur un écran oled néanmoins se
trouve vraiment intéressante
les couleurs sont assez ok par contre un
truc est vachement vachement important à
mon avis dès que vous arrivez dès que
vous allumez votre smartphone vous avez
tout de suite dans l'affichage vous
allez tout de suite dans le mode est
température de couleurs par défaut les
crocs calibré comme ça vous êtes sur des
lumières vives et vous êtes par défaut
ici vous avez des couleurs qui sont
extrêmement contrastés alors je sais pas
là si vous vous en rendrez compte parce
qu'une colorimétrique est fait sur la
vidéo mais c'est très contrastées là
c'est à ces bleus ça fait assez mal aux
yeux ce que je vous conseille c'est de
vous mettre sur un mode normal déjà ça
casse un petit peu le côté bleu t on à
un peu plus joli
les couleurs sont beaucoup plus douce il
vous invite même à aller directement ici
haut niveau la température des couleurs
sur chaude ça va continuer à jouer ni à
légèrement et à mon avis ça pour pouvoir
reposer vos yeux c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal
que ce soit pour visionner des vidéos ou
jouer à des jeux l'écran du smartphone
fait l affaire est franchement très très
agréable alors attention pour le côté
multimédia on va pas dans le truc le
plus dingue que vous mettre le son à
fond voilà la chaux-de-fonds vous avez
un haut parleur mono qui s'était juste
là ya du faux très clairement mais c'est
pas complètement le son est assez médium
mais qui dans l'absolu savage de connu
franchement pire maintenant ce qu'il va
chemin bien c'est que huawei a conservé
la prise jack
donc là vous pouvez venir prendre votre
casque alors je vous conseille de
prendre un casque audio de plutôt bonne
qualité plutôt que celui qui fournit à
l'intérieur tu fera le job mais qui sera
pas forcément terrible terrible
et là vous arrivez dans une autre
dimension c'est tout de suite beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mieux à la
qualité beaucoup plus intéressante vous
avez un spectre qui est quand même
vachement mieux et l'expérience c'est
intéressant d'autant plus que vous avez
une optimisation logiciel quelque chose
que vous retrouvez uniquement 15 qu'il
faut que votre prise jack soit branché
vous aller dans les paramètres vous
allez dans son et là vous allez pouvoir
activer en bas ce qu'ils appellent les
effets sonores huawei easton là haut up
bourré le faire alors par défaut il est
en automatique moi ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est de le mettre en
naturel
j'ai vraiment aimé je trouve que c'est
assez intéressant savourez aux biens les
bases vous avez la voix qui sort assez
clairement ça dépend du style de musique
que vous écoutez pour moi le doubs 3d ça
fait un espèce de des faits de
réverbération qui est pas extraordinaire
sinon vous mettez sur standard
choisissez votre type de casque moi j'ai
ni casque / oreilles vous pouvez mettre
écouteurs ou oreillette comme vous le
souhaitez et or tu peux venir régler ici
votre équaliseur bande par bande à
quelque chose près réglée ici de pouvoir
booster vos basses oui ou non
et sinon vous avez quelques préceptes
qui existent directement facettes c'est
vraiment bien il faut profiter d'une
bonne expérience audio multimédia il
vous faut un petit casque alors
attention n'écoutait pas de façon trop
trop prolongée au casque pour éviter de
voir en dessous
le smartphone en lui même est bien ça
n'a pas que ce smartphone le plus
puissant comparer l'impétrante pro
forcément voilà c'est pas tout à fait
dans la même gamme
on a un socle milieu de gamme 5 irin 710
qui couplé à 4 gigas de ram je dirais
que pour les usages standard pour ce que
vous allez en faire dans les trois
quarts des cas ça fonctionnera
parfaitement bien vous n'avez pas
forcément faire du multitâche si vous
jouez déjà peu plus gourmand vous aurez
pas la meilleure qualité graphique mais
par contre pour un usage standard pour
tout ce que vous allez pouvoir en faire
du multimédia des jeux vidéo pas trop
gourmand bien évidemment pour des
réseaux sociaux il ira parfaitement bien
il est assez fluide pour ma part je n'ai
pas rencontré de problème côté stockage
et libyens vous avez carrément 128 giga
à l'intérieur vous avez le temps de voir
venir et si vous êtes un peu plus
gourmand aux gourmandes vous pouvez
rajouter ici une carte microsd monté
jusqu'à 512 gia de stockage autant dire
que là vous allez franchement de quoi
faire je vous le dis en préambule de
vidéos c'est soit une deuxième carte
s'il soit la carte microsd bon voilà à
voir en fonction de vos usages haut
niveau de l'eau est s'entendent sur le
m8 9.0.1 sur l'android 9 paille
alors bon ça fonctionne il ya pas mal de
petites choses que vous pouvez faire
avec notamment la navigation par gestes
moi c'est ce que je fais ce que
j'utilise et je trouve qui est bien
mieux que d'avoir la navigation à trois
touches un petit peu standard c'est
pratique pour avancer sportive pour
reculer en plus du point de vue logiciel
ça vous permet d'utiliser huawei cher
j'ai mon macbook 13 2019 qui est là et
là j'ai mon smartphone ce que je fais je
prends mon smartphone je le pose la
petite vibration et la photo par
directement ici sur mon écran ça c'est
vachement bien alors je vous ai déjà
parlé devant richert dans la vidéo de
présentation du macbook 13
c'est un truc qui est vraiment cool vous
invite à aller voir cette vidéo ça vous
intéresse parce que ça c'est vraiment
génial
côté sécurité pour le déverrouiller que
le capteur d'empreintes digitales
pulsionnel arrière qui marchent
vachement bien un 2 3 on appuie saad et
verrouille tout de suite ça s'est
vraiment bien ou alors vous avez la
reconnaissance faciale directement votre
caméra c'est parce qu'elle plus sécurisé
mais dans l'absolu ça fonctionne
parfaitement bien
côté autonomie vous allez le garder une
journée une journée
ça va vraiment dépendre de votre
utilisation si vous êtes quelqu'un qui
utilisation tu peux intensive une tour
des guillemets quand je dis ça beaucoup
de réseaux sociaux des jeux de la vidéo
vous garderez une journée si maintenant
vous avez une consommation qui est assez
modérée vous pouvez garder une journée
demi on n'a pas une énorme batterie on a
une batterie de 3340 meilleure paire eur
ce pardon vu un truc de fou mais sera
parfaitement la faire vous avez de la
recharge en usb cesser la recharge
rapide 18 watts on n'aura pas une
recharge aussi rapide que sur le pétrole
promener en moins ça ira très bien il se
recharge assez rapidement et je dirais
que celui là il vous laissera jamais
tomber
il a du bluetooth 4.2 il a du nfc pour
moi hier entre autres et aussi pour
votre pass navigo si vous êtes parisien
et l'arrière vous avez un triple module
photo une caméra principale de 48
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8 un deuxième
module photo 8 mégapixels qui voit f 2.4
qui est le l'ultra grand-angle et un
troisième appareil photo de 2 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui servira surtout
pour les faits bocquet d'avant vous avez
une caméra de 24 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.0
à la différence du pétrole pro qui est
probablement l'un des meilleur
photophone si ce n'est le meilleur sur
le pétrole live vous avez des photos qui
sont corrects
ici pas de partenariat avec les cas et
si vous avez par un truc de fou
forcément il ya une grosse différence
entre un produit milieu de gamme est un
produit très haut de gamme
forcément il ya payet qui est énorme il
suffit pas qu'à des déviations p 30 pour
en faire un produit d'exception
né au mollet sur un produit qui est très
honnête et qui vous sort des photos qui
sont relativement correct qui suit pas
de fioritures dès lors vous avez de la
lumière ça marche et ça marche plutôt
bien les fraises sont belles les bananes
donne faim et on voit la can à l'issic
est juste magnifique
les couleurs sont assez correct c'est
pas non plus un truc absolument dingue
le point c'était pas trop mal c'est pas
le meilleur smartphone en termes de
photos mais dans l'absolu c'est pas le
pire non plus même pour les petits
bonshommes muguet ça fait là faire les
photos sont assez honnête a volé je vous
montre un peu si l'on met sur une
feuille qui était prise
juste tout à l'heure ça marche bien
c'est moi qui suis venu lab rapprochés
on est assez de détails on voit quand
même les détails je peux venir ou mais
davantage pour repère franchement le
veinage de la feuilleraie du détail
bon ça va c'est quand même relativement
correct là il a eu un petit peu de mal à
faire le point dessus sur celle là
c'était mieux
c'est un tout qui joue un peu contre
away parce que quand on pense au wawel
porte tout de suite excellent photophone
on pense mais devint propre ans p 20 po
on pense p30 pro en pense excellent
photophone on pense très belles photos
très bon rendu photo et c'est vrai quand
on arrive sur un produit comme celui là
qui appelle tout 369 euros d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas pour aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil on se dit ah bah la photo s'est
pas complètement ça et c'est ce que je
vous disais il souffre de son nom p30
lite on n'est pas sur le paie 30 pro ou
même le paie 30
on est sur le paie 30 light et c'est
vrai que c'est trois caractères au début
p30 peuvent vous faire oublier qu'il
s'agit d'un produit milieu de gamme est
tout de suite on risque d'être un peu
déçu parce qu'on pourrait s'attendre à
un truc génial en termes de photos avec
moi ouais alors on n'est pas sur un
photophone on n'est pas sur un
smartphone qui est fait pour faire des
photos incroyables
on est sur un smartphone qui est fait
pour vous donner des résultats
équilibrés que vous puissiez utiliser
aussi bien pour faire quelques souvenirs
quelques photos souvenirs pour pouvoir
jouer à quelques jeux pour pouvoir ont
repéré avec votre gps pour pouvoir
regarder des vidéos pour écouter un peu
de musique
on est sur un smartphone équilibrée que
ce n'est pas un smartphone qui tend plus
vers la photo plusieurs autres choses
on est sur un produit qui est correct
qui marche bien qui se tient qu'ils
aient un tarif intéressant 369 euros
dans cette gamme de prix
ça va franchement il est vraiment bien
avec de la recharge rapide ça va moi je
trouve assez intéressant dites moi ce
que vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
vous ce p 30 light est ce qu'il vous
séduit vous aimez ces petites couleurs
est ce que ça vous dérange le fait
maintenant qu'on essaie petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales ici au centre est
ce que vous le trouvez bien oui non quoi
comment est ce qu'ils les boîtes on sait
que le pv light avait eu un énorme
succès et dernière d'ailleurs c'est au
jour d'aujourd'hui
ma plus grosse vidéo c'était une plus de
vies en tout cas sur machines multi
vendeurs et 400000 juste un truc assez
énorme je procède pas les dernières en
levant une vidéo sur le pv light avoir
de tels scores allez savoir avec le pétr
en cas que vous cache parce que c'est un
très bon rapport qualité prix et c'est
pour ça qu'en tout cas le pv light est
peut-être le pétr anglais cette année a
eu sur le pétrole a été peut-être
celui-là le pétrole light
un excellent succès a vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
donne rendez vous dès demain des
surprises
plein de choses très intéressantes vous
en dit pas plus à demain tchaourou